what's your bet on Kanye getting back
with Adidas
[Laughter]
that's how sure I am if Kanye gets
backwards you suck something not
happening yo neither one of those things
are happening
so I'm confident with that bet really
it's not happening get back with Adidas
what if they just come to an agreement
to sell the existing back stock well
that's different how's that doing even
though I've seen that story but I don't
believe that story about that
they come to an agreement to sell the
existing back stock I don't I don't if
they do that will you I don't think
Adidas slips on it I don't think Adidas
risk uh their overall brand doing
something like that Sunday took too big
of a loss why do y'all keep saying that
well they losing money on Beyonce
it's a billion dollars a year in Revenue
we're not saying that a billion dollars
isn't a loss but y'all make it seem like
Adidas is going under do you all realize
this company has been around for
hundreds of years no I didn't know that
hundreds I don't know about hundreds at
least a hundred I don't think so look it
up all right let's see pounds
I don't think you know how Nazis 1949 do
the math I don't [__] that's 100 years
wow you're right that's what I'm saying
20 billion plus years
they make over 20 billion a year in
Revenue you know what your problem is
what's my problem you believe that Kanye
West who [__] yeah
and I can't wait when he's back and
you're going to be wrong and you're
gonna have to suck something Adidas is
not going to do that first of all why
would a company that's making 20 billion
dollars in Revenue risk bringing in
one guy has gone probably ostracized so
many people away from your brand why
would you do that you would have what if
uh football soccer fight for them say
you know what y'all in business with
Kanye we don't want nothing to do with
y'all whatever the [__]
he said fight
yeah what if they say oh y'all in
business with Kanye we don't want to be
in business with y'all now you talking
about losing some goddamn Revenue yep
now you're you're dealing with a partner
that walked away and Kanye is not gonna
shut the [__] up no to make you yeah I
think he learned from this no he never
learned in his life Val man where's the
atonement in his life where's your told
me he's shutting up where's the dick
sucking yeah you gotta suck some goddamn
thing circumcised dick yeah yeah so so
is that is that the price that he has to
pay
is that what you're saying that Kanye
should right I think Kanye is no
different than uh the dude from Dilbert
Scott Adams okay stop volunteering your
feelings about marginalized communities
nobody [__] asked you bro yeah Scott
Adams wanted to go Defcon three on black
people Kanye went Defcon 3 on Jewish
people and for what let's look at the
Dilbert situation they're down 37 but
it's been like that may 2022 though
this [__] had to do with China
um the the Ukraine Russia [__] yeah
because they pulled out of Russia
because of the war when did the Kanye
[__] drop I think it was like November
the bottom is November well that's way
they still have Kanye well this [__] has
been happening Adidas stock has been
going down for like the last two years
and it's been going up and down like
most stocks do I don't know they had to
pull out they pulled out of Russia
Russia was a big market for them yeah
and I think it's a lot of a lot of
influx going on in Europe because of
that that whole Russia Ukraine Invasion
then it was something with China that
had their their stocks [__] up and
it's not just them it's Nike everybody
sneakers
like the track suits in Russia
the whole economy
but Nike stocks are down like 13 as well
yeah it's not just Adidas I don't know
why y'all are attributing Adidas being
down to Kanye that's I mean not saying
that he's not a part of it but he's not
a large part of which but he was
responsible for a lot of their sales
yeah and now they're not getting those
sales I think he was responsible for
more than profits than their revenue
well you need Revenue to make profits
but no their revenue was 20 billion a
year yeah he was responsible for some of
it I think their overhead is so low and
Yeezy you know I don't know how much it
cost to make it easy but I think they're
overhead is so low that him bringing in
a projected 1.3 billion is a lot I mean
I don't know how much it costs to make
easys I don't know I don't know if it's
still even if it's even if it's 1.3
billion right what is that five percent
six percent I think they said he was
their total revenue I think it was like
seven six to seven or something like
that okay yeah you can take a hit how
much eight percent they're saying that
Yeezy generated 1.7 billion in annual
revenue which is eight percent of the
total and the net profit on that's 246
million in either case they're going to
write this off it's something about the
big number they might donate all the
back stock to kids in Africa and then
all those kids would be looking fly as
hell so I see I think there's actually
an upside the kids actually helping give
kids